si ya ha comenzado la 'operación salida'
para las celebraciones de este fin de
semana largo del 4 de julio en el que se
espera que millones de personas se
desplacen para ser el fin de semana de
mayor movimiento desde que comenzó el
año dicen los expertos y se espera que
13 millones de personas pasen por los
aeropuertos de este país
igualando casi las cifras de movimiento
del 2019 antes de que llegara el
coronavirus todo un desafío para los
aeropuertos que como saben están
lidiando con la falta de pilotos y con
los constantes retrasos en los vuelos de
hecho hay aerolíneas que están
ofreciendo un cambio de billete de
manera gratuita para poder hacer frente
a esa avalancha de pasajeros la
situación no es mucho mejor en carretera
desde luego van a ser las vacaciones más
caras a la que los estadounidenses se
enfrenten por ese por esos altos precios
históricos altos precios de la gasolina
ahora mismo superan los tres dólares el
galón dicen los expertos que va a haber
estaciones de servicio que se queden sin
suministro y que los estadounidenses van
a pagar 143 más caro el galón de lo que
lo pagaron el año pasado a pesar de
estos datos la asociación americana del
automóvil asegura que se va a batir otro
récord 42 millones de personas se espera
que se desplace en este fin de semana
por carretera